la misión cumplida o eso aseguran estas
imágenes publicadas por el ejército de
etíopes afirman que sus tropas ya han
entrado a mekelle el ejército confirmó
que ya capturó la ciudad capital de la
región separatista de tigre sin víctimas
civiles de nuestro ejército después de
haberse preparado ayer sobre cómo
controlar la ciudad de messina causar
daños colaterales ha tomado el control
total de merkel desde esta tarde las
personas vuelan a mcallen el muro
el gobierno dice que liberó a unos 7.000
soldados federales que habían sido
hechos prisioneros y ahora está
procediendo a perseguir a los líderes
rebeldes del frente de liberación
popular de tigre el primer ministro
etíope había met escribió un tuit en el
que aseguró que las operaciones habían
llegado a su fin en la región mientras
tanto el frente de liberación popular de
tigre asegura que me que le ha sido
objeto de bombardeos durante los últimos
días el fin de semana pasado el gobierno
emitió una advertencia de que me que le
sería bombardeado indiscriminadamente a
menos que los rebeldes dejasen las armas
por su parte el líder de tigre aseguró
que sus fuerzas tienen la intención de
seguir luchando y afirmó que se trata de
defender su derecho a la
autodeterminación el frente de
liberación dominó en el pasado una
coalición gobernante en etiopía antes de
ser marginado por amplias reformas
políticas lideradas por arabia med desde
su ascenso al poder en 2018 las
afirmaciones del gobierno nacional y del
ejército de liberación son casi
imposibles de verificar ya que la región
permanece prácticamente aislada se cree
que miles de personas murieron en los
combates desde que comenzó la campaña
militar del gobierno para recuperar
el control de tigre hace tres semanas